[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Just a couple of
days ago, actually,
they were shooting by my best
friend's house, so it was,
kind of-- yeah.
- And, like, you
never know what type
of car going to drive
past and do some shooting.
You come down south,
or come over east,
or something like
that, it's going
to-- you're going to
see run-down buildings,
abandoned buildings, home--
a lot of homeless people,
like, a lot of, just, bad.
- My name is [? Cordell ?]
[? Samson. ?]
- My name is Mariah Lopez.
- My name is
[? Ramil ?] [? Ward. ?]
- My name is [? Jetly ?]
[? Henderson. ?]
- I'm from 59th and Aberdeen,
Southside of Chicago.
- The Eastside of Chicago.
- I stay on 80th and Saginaw.
- I am from Chicago, Illinois.
And I-- I live on--
I heard about My Block,
My Hood, My City.
At first, I had saw
a video on YouTube
with a person wearing a My
shirt-- a regular sweatshirt.
And then I also heard
about it from my principal.
- Hi, my name is Vincent Gay.
I'm the founding Principal
at Baker College Prep.
I heard about My Block,
My Hood, My City.
Our social worker brought it up.
We were trying to
think of different ways
that we can get our
students exposed
to different parts of Chicago.
And then through
a couple emails,
we were able to connect
with the organization.
- And he said we could be taking
a trip to a White Sox game.
And I was interested in
it, because, like, my mom's
always saying I should
get out the house.
And then so I just
figured, like, why not?
Yeah, I had a good time.
Like, I was talking.
I saw some good swings.
It got me out my comfort
zone, because, like, I'm
not really that type of
person that be going out.
Like, I'm an inside
person most of the time--
all the time, actually.
[MUSIC - COMMON, "BE"]
- That's when we went on the
fieldtrip with my softball team
to the fitness gym.
At the end of the workout,
I actually felt tired.
But it felt, like,
good at the same time.
I felt like-- it kind of
made me feel, kind of, grown.
My favorite part about
the My Block, My Hood,
My City is the
experience that I get
to have of going to
different places,
like when we went
to that restaurant--
the [INAUDIBLE] restaurant.
When we went there--
I'd never been to a
place like that before.
And it was actually
very fun to be
able to experience a
new opportunity to be
able to do something else.
My family, we really
don't really go out much.
And when I go downtown,
I don't really
have enough money
to go out like that.
So it was, kind
of, fun-- it was,
not kind of, but really fun.
- I think My Block,
My Hood, My City
is an amazing organization
which exposes students
from different neighborhoods
to different parts of the city.
What I really like
about it for the school
is, that they are
100% in charge.
We just give the
the list of students
who are going to attend.
And they take it from
the moment that they
pick the kids up at
school until they
bring them back safely as well.
- Like, if I just had, like, a
little taste of what it it is
to have a lot of money,
and be able to do--
take care of my sister, and
my family, and my brothers,
and all of them.
Like, I'd never
want to let that go.
Like, I'm going to keep
working harder and harder
to get to to where I want to be.
- It was awesome, because
I got this, like--
I got to be people--
around people
that was trying to take
us out for a good time,
like, just in case, like, if
our parents didn't ever had time
to do all that.
You know, we have
people at our program
to help us out with that.
- It was basically
like a place for me
to have fun, and, like, take
the negative out, and just keep
everything positive.
- My name is Vincent Gay.
And this is My Block,
My Hood, My City.
- My name is [? Ramil ?]
[? Ward. ?] And this is My
Block, My Hood, My City.
- My name is Mariah Lopez.
And I-- forgot.
[LAUGHTER]
My name is Mariah Lopez.
And I am from My Block,
My Hood, My City.
- OK, my name is [? Jetly ?]
[? Henderson. ?] And I am from
My Block, My Hood, My City.
- My name is [? Cordell ?]
[? Samson. ?] And this is My
Block, My Hood, My City.
- My name is Jahmal Cole.
And this is My Block,
My Hood, My City.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 3: Hello,
Chicago Googlers.
Thank you so much for
joining us on a Friday.
As we were planning, we
know that this office
is fairly busy, and getting more
and more popular with events,
so this is one of the only
times we had available.
And we're super excited.
And wow, this room is
filled, so I'm super pumped.
We've been working
with Jahmal and Codi
in My Block, My Hood, My
City for almost a year now.
And I'm not going to take
too much time up here,
but it's-- they just have
such a fascinating story.
And the reach that
they've been able to make
in the city of
Chicago, and the impact
that they've been able to
have in the lives of so
many kids in this city is just
something that caught our eye.
And it's-- we're really, really
excited about the partnerships
we've had with
this organization.
There's a lot of people
doing good in this city,
but when you talk, and
you'll hear from Jamal,
like, someone who is truly
passionate about putting
his life on the line, and
really making sure that he's
out there for the kids.
And he'll talk about some of the
risks that he's taken his life.
But it's really,
for me, it's just
been, sort of, a good
person to look up to,
in terms of how much
commitment and giving back
to the community you can do.
So, again, super
excited that you all
are here to listen
to his message,
and let's give him
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
JAHMAL COLE: Last
night I couldn't sleep.
You know, it wasn't
because we don't have heat.
Like, not having heat on
my block is regular stuff.
We heat the house with the
oven, go back to sleep.
But I still couldn't
sleep last night.
You know, it wasn't
because I heard gunshots--
[POW] [POW].
I mean, I hear gunshots
all the time on my block.
Hearing gunshots
is regular stuff.
I tell myself
they're firecrackers.
I go back to sleep, no biggie.
But I still couldn't
sleep last night.
You know, it wasn't
because of the helicopters
flying over my house.
Hearing helicopters
is regular stuff.
They fly over every night.
I couldn't sleep, because, the
lights from the helicopters,
they were shining
through my window.
They had the whole
block lit up at 2:00 AM.
Like broad day, you
could see every bullet
casing on the ground.
I couldn't sleep.
I live in a house with my
Aunt and her husband, Marvin.
Both of them are drug addicts.
The last time I see
my Aunt, she came
into the house with a black
t-shirt with a Batman logo
on the chest, and half
of her ear was missing.
And she lay on the
kitchen floor, bleeding.
She got into a fight with
the drug addict outside,
by the way.
My house is run by
my older cousins.
Both of them are in gangs.
And both them sell drugs.
But nobody says that, being
in a gang is regular stuff.
They say, this is my set.
These are my friends.
I'm maintaining.
I love my older cousins.
I love them.
They tell me I'm smart.
My teachers don't
tell me I'm smart.
My cousins say I'm smart,
because I'm the lookout.
I know all nine cars that are
supposed to be on my block.
I know there's a Chevy
with a black tint,
a baby-blue Cadillac, a van
with the curtains in it,
the man with the motorcycle,
or royal-blue Acura,
a Toyota Camry with a City
College bumper sticker,
a lady with a Cherokee,
this all-black Charger
with silver rims, and there's
a brown Honda minivan.
And if any one of those
nine cars aren't there
and someone else pulls
up, I tell my cousins.
They say I'm a smart--
I'm the lookout.
I order my food in the morning
through bulletproof glass
windows with mugshots of
black faces on the front.
There's no microphone, so
I have to yell my order
to the guy behind the counter.
I say, hey, I want the Doritos.
No, not the Spicy Nachos.
I want the Blue Ranch, the
blue bag, the blue bag,
the blue bag.
He goes and gets it.
And he drops my Doritos inside
the bulletproof glass drawer.
And he slides it out to me,
like he's a prison guard
and I'm an inmate in
solitary confinement.
I'm in the real world, though.
There's ShotSpotters on the
poles, blue lights flashing.
German Shepherds sniff us
when you get on the train.
If society was a
person, I wouldn't
think society liked
me, so I steal anyway.
I am looking forward to
going to school today,
because I'm a part of
the after-school program.
It's called My Block,
My Hood, My City.
It's ran by this guy
named Jahmal Cole.
I believe in him.
Jahmal is always
saying, he can't
afford to take us to China,
so he takes us to Chinatown.
He can't afford to
take us to Poland,
so he takes us to
Jefferson Park.
He can't afford to
take us to India,
so he takes us to Divine Avenue.
Jahmal is always saying
we can travel the world
without leaving Chicago.
Just last week, Jahmal
took us downtown.
And we went to a museum.
But the coolest part about
the trip was not the museum,
the coolest part was that,
you know, I never seen
anybody wave for a taxi before.
And Jahmal let us
all wave for taxis.
And we got to ride a few blocks.
I thought that was amazing.
I was telling Jahmal that I
don't like to go see my Father,
because he just got out of jail.
And he's on house arrest.
And every time I see him,
he sends me on errands.
I noticed, the last
time I was over there,
my Mom posted a picture of
her and her new boyfriend
on Facebook.
And my Dad liked that picture.
But when my Mom
posted a picture of me
having a 3.2 GPA on Facebook,
my Dad never liked that picture.
And that bothered me.
My name is Jahmal Cole.
I thought it was important
to start off, and paint
that picture, because the more
we're separated as a city,
the less empathy we
have for each other.
When most people hear
about something negative
happening in another
Chicago community,
especially where people look
a lot different from them,
it might as well happen
in another country.
But when you visit
different communities
and you interact
with the residents,
you can change all that.
I grew up in a household
where my older cousins
are both-- one is doing 80,
one is doing 40 years in jail.
I love my cousins--
love them.
I still write them.
I write them by hand, so they
can know I still love them.
Last letter, I said, hey
man, how's it going in there?
How's it going?
He said, you know what,
Jamal, on my block-- in jail,
there's blocks--
A block, B block, C block--
he said on my block,
you know, there's no pedophiles.
You know, on my block, someone
might have sold a little drugs,
caught a homicide,
racketeering-- you know,
regular stuff.
It is not regular
to have to order
your food through
three-inch bulletproof glass
windows in the morning.
If I put a three-inch
bulletproof glass window
in the Gold Coast,
they would have a fit.
It is not regular
for German Shepherds
to sniff you when you get
on the train in the morning.
It's not regular for people
to check your receipts
when you're leaving the store.
It is not regular
for helicopters
to fly over your house at night.
They say my program works
with at-risk teenagers.
I think the
integrity of our city
is at risk if we're
not supporting programs
that are focused on teenagers.
I was born on the Greyhound bus.
Not literally, but it's a place
where the most formative years
of my life took place.
Every time my Father and
my Mother would break up,
I'd take the Greyhound from
Chicago to Fort Worth, Texas.
Yeah, you can imagine
an 11-year-old
taking the train to Texas.
That's not the safest thing,
but those experiences,
they really transformed me.
Any fears I had of being in a
new or foreign place, that was
overcome by sheer curiosity.
I became somewhat of an
amateur anthropologist.
You know, we'd head
from the cornfields of--
you know, the concrete of
Chicago to the cornfields
a greater Illinois.
I get out of Memphis, Tennessee;
Little Rock, Arkansas.
I notice the sights, the
sounds the food, the scenery.
I expanded my world view.
While volunteering
at Cook County Jail,
and talking with
the young men there,
it became clear
that a lot of them
had never traveled
outside of their block.
I said, where you from?
They say, my block
is 21st Street.
My hood is the low end.
I said, well what
about your city?
To me, it was tragic they
had never left anywhere.
So I started a program,
where I take teenagers
from the block on
educational field trips.
And we expose them to
different cultures,
different professions,
and different cuisines.
And that's what we do.
I believe exposure is key to
solving violence in the city.
My Father, my role model--
I went to a alternative
high school.
I said, I want to go to college.
I told my guidance counselor,
I want to go to college.
She said, you don't need to
go to a alternative school.
You know, why do you
want to go to college?
Go to the Army.
Go to the military.
Go to a trade school.
Her phone rang.
She left the office.
I took a book off of her shelf.
It said All-American Colleges.
I ripped a page out.
It said, Wayne State Nebraska.
I was like, ah, Nebraska!
I was so mad.
I was like, why couldn't it
have said Florida or New York.
It's Nebraska.
It's crazy.
That was my options.
So prior to this, I only
applied to one college.
I applied to one
college senior year.
And that was Howard University.
And that's because Sean
Puffy Combs went there.
And I was like, man, I want to
start my own business, right?
But two weeks before
graduation, I had never--
I hadn't heard back.
And them applications
was like $75.
I didn't hear anything back.
Two weeks before high
school graduation,
I'm in my guidance
counselor's office.
And I take this paper, and
shove it in my pocket--
Wayne State College.
She comes back, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, telling me--
she was telling me the
truth, at the time.
But as a kid, you know, I'm--
you know, I wanted
to go to the NBA.
That's what I wanted to do.
I'm going to college.
I go downstairs.
I dial 402-375-7000.
Nancy was her name.
Hey, do you guys got
a basketball team?
Yes.
Do you guys got a
history program?
Yes.
Cool.
God was shining on me,
because they accepted kids
from alternative
high schools, it
didn't matter what your GPA was.
They accepted me.
I walked around with that
acceptance letter in my pocket
all summer.
I showed it to my friends.
I got my jaw broke.
You leaving the block?
Now you going nowhere.
I got my jaw broke.
I showed acceptance
letter to my Mom.
You trying to be white.
Do you think you're
better than all of us?
You going to college?
You ain't better than us.
Took my car away from me.
I went to my Father.
I showed him this
acceptance letter.
He Stole a U-Haul truck,
took me to Nebraska.
Now, when you're 17 years
old, you get a credit card
in the mail for a $500 limit.
We used that credit card to
put gas in the U-Haul truck
to get to Nebraska.
I had nothing in the back
of a big U-Haul truck
with a cornstalk
symbol on the side.
I had some Air Force 1s,
a Michigan State visor,
and a few white t-shirts--
I didn't know-- what's the
weather like in Nebraska?
Who knows?
We took off.
15 minutes before we
pulled up to Wayne State,
my dad was telling
me, man, you've
already accomplished more
than anybody in this family.
There's really nothing
else I can tell you,
but I wanted to let you know
that Howard University--
excuse me, I might get
emotional about it.
But he said, Howard
University sent that letter.
And they didn't accept you.
And I didn't show it
to you, because I knew
you'd be like your cousins.
I knew you'd be
like your brothers.
I knew you would give up.
I knew it would be
devastating to you.
That was one of the best things
anybody had ever done to me.
So when I graduated
college at Wayne State,
I come back to Chicago,
and start volunteering
in a Cook Count Jail.
Because I'm a graduate
of alternative
high school, and
going to college
was exposure that I needed.
It showed me the world doesn't
end at the corner of my block.
We can dream bigger
than our surroundings.
We work with 120 kids
from the lowest performing
schools in Chicago--
the lowest performing.
We say, what do you want to be?
They say, I want to be a rapper.
I want to be a
basketball player.
We take them to Gatorade.
They talk to them about
consumer engagement.
They never knew that job existed
prior to that educational field
trip.
We take them to Google.
And we use VR goggles.
We get to explore places
through the Expedition Program.
They're getting
hands-on experience
with people like Roberto,
and the other people here.
That is powerful.
They know it's possible
now, because of our program.
Thank you guys for having me.
JEN WESLEY: Thank you, Jahmal.
That was--
JAHMAL COLE: Thank you.
JEN WESLEY: --very moving.
JEN WESLEY: I really
appreciate you coming today.
JAHMAL COLE: Thanks
for having me.
JEN WESLEY: Roberto
and the whole team
here has been thinking
a lot about My Block,
My Hood, My City.
And we're excited
to hear your story.
The timing couldn't
be more perfect,
with your book just
coming out this week--
or was it last week?
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah,
it was Saturday, so,
yeah, it just came out.
JEN WESLEY: You can download
this on Google Play,
as well as keep your
copy from today.
JAHMAL COLE: Cool.
JEN WESLEY: I was
really moved by hearing
your story about college
acceptance and rejection.
And one of the things you
talk about in your book
is, how many grants
you've had to apply for
as you started My
Block, My Hood, My City.
I'm wondering if you could
talk to us a little bit
about the story of
resilience that you
explain in this-- in the
book-- getting the rejection,
being able to, not even
read more than one sentence,
and know where it's going,
and how you bounced back
and keep going with your vision.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, so when you--
it's hard to write
grants, you know?
You don't know what they want.
And just because you started
a program doesn't mean
you know how to write out a
mission statement perfectly,
or you know how to track
the data perfectly.
God's working through you.
And you have a vision,
but for grants, they
want copy-pastable data.
And so, yeah, I got turned
down by a lot of grants.
But when they start sending
me the email saying,
hey, you're not going to get
this grant, I just started--
I recognized, you
know, this oh, they're
not going to give it to me.
But you know what,
it's inconsequential.
It doesn't make a lot of--
it doesn't make a difference
to me, because I sell hoodies.
I sell t-shirts.
And I use that money to
take kids around the city.
So people recognize
that exposure is key.
And the power will
travel as transformative.
And I will stand Downtown
in front of Foot Locker
and sell t-shirts.
I will do whatever I got to do
to get these teenagers access
to opportunities.
And one thing I've learned,
if you do what you love to do,
you organically build
relationships that
will help you be successful.
JEN WESLEY: So you take
kids outside of Chicago,
as well as into Chicago.
You've been everywhere from
Lake Michigan, to DC, to Ghana.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, yeah.
JEN WESLEY: And
do you personally
go on all those trips?
JAHMAL COLE: I do.
I do, but we're
getting bigger now,
so I don't get to go on
as many as I'd like to.
And it's hard for me
to let go of my babies.
I love them.
But it has to happen.
We have 120 to 150 kids right
now, that we serve per month.
But yeah, so we take
kids to the Greektown.
And we'll explore the National
Hellenic Museum, or the Athena
Greek Restaurant.
And we might visit, you know,
Havas Worldwide International,
you know, advertising firm.
And one of the kids said, the
only Greek food he ever tasted
was a gyro from Aldi's.
You know, and so it's
like, that's the only--
and again, when they
get Downtown Chicago,
they've never, like--
the elevators that are
here with no buttons
on the elevator, that'd
just blow their mind.
They'd be like, hey, there's
no buttons on the elevator.
The things we take for
granted are fish-out-of-water
experiences for teenagers
from under-resourced Chicago
communities.
JEN WESLEY: That's awesome.
So one of the
things you mentioned
is the idea of expanding
your world view.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah.
JEN WESLEY: And the truth is
that a lot of people at Google,
surprisingly, we need to
expand our world view, as well.
We get very comfortable
in the bubble that
is working in the West Loop,
without even any traffic,
and access to lunch--
I mean, definitely a
different experience
than the kids you're spending
time with, and taking
around Chicago.
What would be your
recommendation to our team,
so that they could get--
expand their world view,
and get exposure themselves?
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, to
truly make our city better,
we need more people to explore
communities outside their own,
right?
It is not true.
A lot of things in the media
get said to sell papers.
There's 2.7 million
people in Chicago.
We know that there's
1,200 people that's
doing the shooting,
doing the violence.
The most dangerous streets,
like 79th Street, that they say
is dangerous, I jog down
that street every day.
And say hi to my
neighbors every day.
It's just not true.
You have to have an
appetite for adventure.
Just like you would
study hard for an exam,
or you would exercise, you
have to exercise your empathy
towards the suffering of
other people in Chicago.
And once we do that, we'll
stop seeing ourselves
as part of 77 different
community areas.
And we'll see ourselves as
part of a greater whole,
and one Chicago.
JEN WESLEY: I like that idea
of exercising your muscle
to go and see other things,
and do different things.
I think you also,
you have a daughter.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, a
six-year-old daughter, yup.
She's six, going on
25, but, yeah, she's--
[LAUGHTER]
She's already using the virtual
reality goggles from Google,
so shout out to Google for
those, because she does it--
JEN WESLEY: If you keep her with
the virtual reality glasses,
she won't leave
you, so that's good.
JAHMAL COLE: Oh
Lord, every night--
I'm, like, trying to watch
the Cubs game last night.
She's like, I want
to do the goggles.
I'm like, no,
Zobrist is up to bat.
Chill out.
[LAUGHTER]
But it is what it is.
JEN WESLEY: That's awesome.
Six years old, and she knows
how to use virtual reality.
You're on the right track.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah,
she's amazing.
She's teaching me how
to be a better Pops.
And I'm-- yeah, I'm blessed.
I'm blessed.
JEN WESLEY: That's great.
Well, we were reading
your Twitter feed,
so that's how I get to know your
daughter was, and everything.
But one of the things
that you talked about
is, just this
notion that we have
to look around the corner,
wherever we are, and get
into every part of our city.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah.
JEN WESLEY: What would
you say is the place,
or the trip that
you've taken the kids
on that really changed--
had the biggest impact on you.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah,
I would say that--
we take them to the
homeless shelters.
And we give back, first.
That's always the best
exploration for them,
because we're giving
them stuff all the time,
taking them places,
paying for food for them.
But at the beginning
of the year,
we always take them all to
give back, and pass out food
at Catholic Charities.
And you know, I grew
up homeless, you know?
And so I know what
it's like to--
I didn't know what volunteer
groups were when I was a kid,
but I just knew the
people behind the counter
at Thanksgiving at the shelter
that were giving me food,
they were very nice people.
And I said, when I get older,
I want to be like that.
And so I just
remember being really
embarrassed at that time of,
like, you know, high school.
People would see me.
And they'd be volunteering.
But I'd take the food.
But anyway, when I
got older, I said
that that's a meaningful
deposit into your life.
And so I want teenagers to know
what it's like to give back.
So that's-- they
always say, hey,
this is my favorite
exploration, because, you know,
I realize that homeless people
aren't-- they've fallen on bad
times.
It's not like they
asked to be homeless.
They actually could have
been-- had a great job,
and been laid off.
And now their family
has no place to stay,
So they get to develop
empathy, and we--
by going to give back.
JEN WESLEY: That was an
interesting part of the story
when, you talked about
taking the kids to Uptown,
to show them that the Northside
wasn't just this vision they
had created in their minds.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, Uptown
looks like the hood at night.
I mean, if anybody has
been to Uptown, it's a--
Chicago is a city of blocks.
You now, block-by-block,
things can change.
But at the same time, the
people under the bridge--
the bridges in Uptown--
you know, they need our support.
And so what's happening
on Wilson Avenue,
that matters to me, even
though I live on 79th.
You see what I'm saying?
Like, what's happening
in Pilsen matters
to me, even if I live
in Chatham, right?
Those things are interconnected.
And so I want to get
people to think that way.
JEN WESLEY: Well, I think
it's working, for sure.
From what we read in your
book, and what you said today.
JAHMAL COLE: Thank you.
JEN WESLEY: One of the areas
I wanted to ask you about
is, part of this
journey for you--
I mean, this isn't
your first book.
You've written six-- is it six?
Is this the sixth
one, or the fifth one?
JAHMAL COLE: That's
the fifth one-- yeah--
JEN WESLEY: OK,
JAHMAL COLE: --fifth one.
JEN WESLEY: --so, six is coming.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, sure.
JEN WESLEY: You've spent a few
years of your life dedicated
to My Block, My Hood, My City.
And you quit your job to do it.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah.
JEN WESLEY: What's the
hardest thing about that?
JAHMAL COLE: It's tough,
man, when you have to sell--
stand Downtown to sell books
to pay bills for your family.
You know, I'm married.
I got a daughter of six.
And I've got to stand out
in front of Foot Locker,
and do what I got to do.
It's tough when your
water bill goes off.
And you've got to watch
your wife go next door,
and connect the other
neighbor's hose--
a hose to the neighbor's
water, and put--
that sucks.
Like, it sucks.
Like, it really does.
But I got tired of
hearing gunshots.
You know what I mean?
I got tired of it.
I'm jaded from hearing
people make promises.
Like, what's
something simple I can
do that will make a
positive impact on my block?
And how can that send ripple
effects through the city?
So my wife knows who I am.
My heroes are, like,
Robert Kennedy,
Malcolm X, Martin Luther
King Jr. They gave
their life for what they love.
They gave their life for it,
so if I have to risk my home,
if I have to risk
stability, if I have to be--
risk wearing some nice
shoes in front of people,
and keeping up with the
Joneses, I don't care.
In this short moment
of life that I got,
I'm going to do my best
to give teenagers access
to opportunities.
JEN WESLEY: That's
amazing, very inspiring.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah.
JEN WESLEY: I'm
going to just let
people know, if
you have questions,
this would be a time to
think of them, and get ready.
My last question for
you is, what's next?
This is an amazing moment.
You're launching your book.
And we're here to
help you, so tell us
how-- what your vision is, and
how we can be part of that.
JAHMAL COLE: Well, I want to see
my seniors graduate this year.
This is the first
cohort of seniors
that we're going to have.
And they want to
go to Notre Dame.
You know, they want to go to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAHMAL COLE: --LSU.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm going to them there.
And you know, we
went from 60 students
last year, to having
close to 150 right now.
There's a block and a
hood everywhere, right?
So how can we get My Block, My
Hood, My City in Panama, right?
How can we get it in
Harlem Public Schools?
How can we get in Compton
Public Schools, right?
When I say, if you show somebody
better, they'll do better.
That's just not a catch phrase.
What we know intuitively
is backed by a wealth
of youth development research.
And that suggests that
neighborhoods impact teenagers
through exposure-based
influences and forces.
So exposure to institutions
and organizations,
and the quality of safety of
them-- that's a key mechanism,
and through which neighborhoods
impact youth outcomes.
And so I want to continue to
show the world that, hey, these
are not just field trips.
These are educational
explorations,
in which we're making meaningful
deposits into kids life.
And when they come
out of it, they
can say, hey, I want
to work at Google.
There's, 15 minutes
away from here,
kids ordering food through
bulletproof glass right now.
They don't know Google is here.
They don't know these
elevators are here.
They don't know that this is--
and when I take them
into the West Loop,
they look over their shoulder.
And they're like,
wow, like, I don't--
I don't have to be fearful.
Do you know how hard it is
to go to school if you have
to worry about being shot down.
Can you-- like, why do we even
grade people on the same scale.
How-- what is--
does that make sense to you?
It doesn't make sense to me.
How can a kid do well on the
ACT if they've never been
exposed to a ACT practice test.
So I want to--
I think exposure
is key, not just
for inner cities of
Chicago, but inner cities
throughout the country.
JEN WESLEY: Well, one of
the things we'd like to do
is be part of more
of your expeditions.
So I know we talked
before today,
but we're going to
schedule sometimes
for Googlers to go on
expeditions with you,
and bring your kids here,
as well throughout the year,
so that'll be exciting.
JAHMAL COLE: Thank you.
Thank you-- anybody
want to join,
you guys are
definitely welcome too.
We need-- the kids
need exposure.
And they need to meet
mentors, role models
like you all, so thank you.
JEN WESLEY: Any
questions from the group.
I have one more.
AUDIENCE: Just
building on that--
I was curious.
I have a son in pre-school,
and one in fifth grade,
who I would love to bring
on expeditions, too.
So are you thinking this
as [INAUDIBLE] or can we--
JAHMAL COLE: Absolutely.
Absolutely, Codi
Tranel is in back.
She's is our Chief
Operating Officer.
Just make sure you
grab one of our cards
before we leave, because that
is-- we always bring chaperones
on the explorations,
just because we want
to know your world
view, and hear
about your story of
how you got to Google.
A lot of times, things
aren't so linear,
where people, just,
hey, I went to college,
got my Master's degree,
got hired at Google.
Some people got here
through other means.
And that's great
knowledge for teenagers,
because they can
realize that they
don't have to fit in
some kind of certain mold
that society tells them to.
So yeah, that would be great.
Just get-- grab a card.
We want to get
your information--
anybody that wants to go
on explorations can do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
or anything
you might need help with?
JAHMAL COLE: Funding.
[LAUGHTER]
Funding, you know, that comes,
if you're doing what you love.
I think the biggest
problem is, we--
what we're doing
essentially is studying
can we use the power of travel
to defibrillate a kid back
to having hope?
You see, that hasn't been done.
So the metrics that
are out there--
attendance rates, GPA, in-school
suspension, graduation rate,
college persistence-- these
are great things to track.
But we're talking about is,
will the power of travel
have a impact on
a teenager's life.
Long-term, are we
making better citizens?
So it would be helpful to
work with more companies,
to be able to
track data, to work
with people with that study
these things, so that we can--
we don't know we
don't know, right?
And so it's-- we need support.
But also, having a
company like Google say,
hey, this is a great program.
That really helps us out a lot.
JEN WESLEY: And you're
working with some--
at the University
of Chicago to do
some of that studying, right?
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, we do.
We work with the
University of Chicago.
We work with-- unofficially, the
Crime Lab has been helping us
create pre-surveys and
post-surveys for our students,
so we can track if they--
how comfortable do you
feel in your own community?
How connected do
you feel to Chicago?
Do you even know
your community name?
You know, a lot of
our students do not--
like, 75% of our students
don't know what community area
they live in.
At the end of our program,
100% know what community
they live in.
And they know the hidden
gems in their community.
They know the
artful intersections
in their community.
They know the community roots.
They know how to contact
their local official.
They know the faith-based
organizations.
We are building better
citizens through My Block,
My Hood, My City, with
the help of people
that are way smarter than me.
JEN WESLEY: Any other questions?
JAHMAL COLE: How're you doing?
AUDIENCE: Hi, can
you talk more about
how you find students
who are in the program?
And how long are they involved?
Is it like, they go
on one expedition?
Or are they in there
for all high school--
that sort of thing?
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah, so initially,
we wanted to work with a--
I went to a alternative
school, so I
wanted to work with
students that had--
that were a Level 3 school.
So Chicago rates schools
Level 1, Level 2, Level 3
with a school quality
rating report.
And schools that have
lower than 80% attendance,
and a low graduation
rate, they are--
they fall at Level 3.
The issue was, going
to those schools,
and finding students that--
you know, that was
our threshold--
80% attendance.
The problem is that, if a
school has 2,500 capacity,
and there's only 130 kids
that go to the whole school,
and of those 130 kids there's
only a 58% attendance rate,
than the school-- the
students are struggling
through all this data, right?
And so we had to
go to the schools,
and work with the principals
and assistant principals
to find out who is
the most disconnected,
and who can we connect to more
opportunities in the city?
And so, yes, it's a
program where you're
in our program for four years.
So if you start a freshmen, you
take 12 explorations that year.
By senior year,
when you graduate,
you've been exposed to
48 different professions.
And you have 48
different options
to choose from besides violence.
You might say, I want
to be a chiropractor,
or I might want to do
Microsoft engineering.
I might want to work at a bank.
We expose them to 48
different professions
throughout their entire
high school career.
JEN WESLEY: So just to
clarify-- so there's data
that you look at, but sometimes
the data can't even tell you
who are the kids who need
the emotional support
and connection.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah,
because data is important.
And data matters.
I was going to wear a shirt
today that said data matters,
but I was, like, you know,
I'm going to wear My Block,
My Hood, My City.
JEN WESLEY: You don't have
to wear that shirt here.
We know.
JAHMAL COLE: It does.
It matters so much.
It matters so much to funders.
And they want to see the data.
Let me tell you this, though.
Kids believe in me.
And that's why they come back.
They believe in my staff.
That's why they come back.
Because what the
data doesn't say,
is that when the
[INAUDIBLE],, when
Deonte, when their
lights go off,
when their phone goes off, when
they don't got no ride at 2:00
in the morning, are you going
to show up for them or not?
The data doesn't say that.
Guess what?
But having empathy
says, go do that.
And that's why they show
back up to our program.
We have a 100% retention
rate in our program.
Students come back to my--
they're recruiting kids.
And we say, we can only take 15.
There's 70 kids per
school that wants
to be a part of our program.
They know we'll
be there for them.
And everybody that's a part
of My Block, My Hood, My City,
they have those same values.
JEN WESLEY: That's
very meaningful to us,
because we look
at a lot of data.
But at the end of the day,
relationships, commitment,
and empathy are really
what makes things happen,
so that's awesome.
JAHMAL COLE: I love that.
I love how you said that.
JEN WESLEY: I think we
even have some visitors who
came in while we were talking.
JAHMAL COLE: I saw.
I saw-- how you all doing?
JEN WESLEY: Who joined us?
JAHMAL COLE: I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
JEN WESLEY: Was there
students in that group?
I think.
AUDIENCE: From Namaste.
JEN WESLEY: Ah.
JAHMAL COLE: They're
from Namaste.
JEN WESLEY: From Namaste, yeah.
JAHMAL COLE: How is it going?
I love that school.
JEN WESLEY: I thought it
was from My Block, My Hood.
But we can--
JAHMAL COLE: No, we can get--
we would love to be at Namaste,
but your guys' waiting
list is so long.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So, Jahmal, thank
you for being here today.
I'm learning an incredible
amount about what you guys do.
And I realize we
can do a lot more.
One of the things that
strikes me are that I
love your perspective on--
you used-- you overcame
a lot in your story.
And one of the biggest
things you overcame
was the people who you
love, and support you--
still support you-- but
also said, are you too good?
Are you-- what are you
trying to do, right?
How do you think about
helping other kids who
are in that same situation?
Because when they're with you,
when they're with the group,
I imagine they feel terrific.
But then there are so
many individual moments
where they have to have the
resolve, the courage, strength,
the things you did, to say,
if I didn't get into Howard,
I'll get somewhere, right?
I mean, and you kept going.
Like, how do you
think about instilling
that kind of perseverance?
Because I imagine you see it a
lot more, in kids everywhere.
But it also--
I don't know.
It's hard to actually think
about how to really give
somebody that kind of strength.
JAHMAL COLE: It's-- do
it through storytelling.
You tell a kid, hey,
there's a salesman.
There's two salesmen.
And it's raining
really bad outside.
You know, one salesman
looks outside.
And he says, hey, you know,
it's raining real bad.
With weather like this,
the boss can't expect me
to go outside and make sales.
So he stays home, right?
And then the other
salesman, he looks outside.
He sees a storm.
He says, man, it's
raining real bad.
With weather like
this, what a great day
to go outside and make
sales, because everybody
is going to be home,
especially the sales people.
And so I tell the teenagers,
it's the same thing in Chicago.
Because some people say,
man, the city is messed up.
The weather is messed up.
The politicians is messed up.
They're not going
to go to college.
Whereas there are other
kids, same North Lawndale
community-- they're
going to say,
man, the city is messed up.
The weather is messed up.
The police is messed up.
And they're still
going to go to college.
So I, kind of, use storytelling
to get through to him.
And also, we connect
them to mentors.
I mean, that's the best way.
I mean, you can save 10
years by reading a book.
But wow, if you can
connect to somebody that's
a mentor, that can work
with you once a month,
it really breaks down a lot of
those self-confidence issues
and barriers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAHMAL COLE: No problem.
JEN WESLEY: So we
always end our sessions
with a question for
people who are here
to ask us, or tell us, rather.
What are the things
you would ask
of us to do differently
when we leave here today,
or to stop doing?
And how would you ask this group
to make a commitment to you?
JAHMAL COLE: Well, I know
Dr. Martin Luther King says--
he says, in a real sense,
all life is interrelated.
He says, all men are caught
in this inescapable network
of mutuality.
And that's bound by a
single garment of destiny.
He says, what affects one person
directly, affects all of us
indirectly.
He says, I can't be what
I ought to be until, you
are what you ought to be.
And you can't be
what you ought to be,
until I am what I ought to be.
And that's the interrelated
structure of reality.
So in this interconnected
Chicago that I envision, like,
all 77 communities,
they're going
to contribute to the
music of the city--
or this is Google-- the
network in the city.
So the residents
of Humboldt Park,
they be the motherboard,
or whatever.
The residents of Woodlawn,
they be the flash.
No, we're Chatham-- Chatham
is going to be the flash.
The residents of
South Shore, they're
going to be the peripherals.
And if one community
area is struggling,
and they can't play their
part, the entire system
is going to suffer.
And we should all be concerned.
So I would encourage everybody
to step outside their comfort
zone, and expose themself--
like, look up from your cell
phone when you're on the train,
and just see what you can
notice from the sights
and sounds around you.
Go visit a different
community area once a month.
Go get your hair done
somewhere else, right?
That's how Chicago is
going to be better.
They say a chain is only as
strong as the weakest link.
Chicago is only
as strong as it's
most under-resourced community.
And so I encourage
you all to explore,
because you can travel the
world without leaving Chicago.
JEN WESLEY: That's awesome.
Well, I can tell you,
from reading your book,
and our conversation
before, you're
a philosopher, an
activist, an organizer.
You really don't fit one mold.
And that usually means
great things are ahead.
And we really wish the best
for My Block, My Hood, My City.
And we want to be part of
it, so we will definitely
follow through on that
over the coming months.
And I know Google.org
will continue
to follow through on that.
JAHMAL COLE: That's amazing.
Thank you guys for having me.
I appreciate it.
JEN WESLEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Before we go, I
did wan to give you
a chance to just
talk about the donuts
that you brought with you.
JAHMAL COLE: Yeah,
it's Dat Donuts,
right there on-- what is that?
83rd third and Cottage
Grove, Chatham--
you know, that's my community.
Chatham's not a community.
It's a state of mind.
And that state of mind
is you know, like,
African-American
entrepreneurship,
homeownership, manicured
lawns, brick bungalows.
And I'm telling you,
if you have you ever
been to, like, Norwood
Park, or Jefferson Park,
you could-- and then you
see Chatham, you'd be like,
wow, it looks identical.
So you guys can visit Chatham.
We are a great community
on the Southside.
JEN WESLEY: So Donuts
from Chatham, today.
JAHMAL COLE: Yes.
Thank you.
JEN WESLEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]